they sometimes call it little germany
but the our valley is in france on the
border of switzerland
and like germany the economy is strong
and focused on exports
the business climate here stands in
stark contrast to the rest of france
though
small and mid-sized companies dominate
the local economy
while elsewhere in france large
corporations are the usual
this employers produces components for
automotive transmissions
and it's no surprise that some of their
products end up in volkswagen cars
working hours are similar to those in
germany too
we work more than 40 hours a week not
the 35 hours which are the norm in
france
we're here for 40 hours every week
these extra hours cost the company
plenty though
and the higher costs including extra
taxes make companies here less
competitive than rivals in other
countries
but france needs all the tax income it
can get
debt has now reached a high point of
over 93 of total gdp
to save costs many industrial companies
in the r valley outsource their research
and development projects to the same
group of engineers
the owner of a tool company spends about
50 000 euros at the technology center to
keep his products up to date
very small companies can hardly afford
their own r d
that's why we are all in this together
we're competitors but we all have the
same r d problem
french president francois hollande has
promised reforms to save business owners
30 billion euros
that should be enough to encourage
employers to start hiring again
but the reforms are slow in coming
we're still too inflexible here in
france
business owners are reluctant to hire
new people because they cannot be laid
off when business drops off
we need more flexibility
this is the reason unemployment has
reached record highs in france
the government has acknowledged the
problem
now it only has to solve it